the season is far from over but the
first game is over chris
and
big picture
ten to three yeah are you kidding me
right i mean
somebody made the point last night it's
yeah it's like this game was played in
1920s yeah not just the clothing for the
the broadcasters but you know 100 years
yeah it set the game back a hundred
years last night uh what's your big take
away from what we saw well my big
takeaway is we wanted questions answered
one about the packers offense and then
two
a little bit about mitch trubisky and
the bears offense and neither of them
were answered at all i mean i think
that's my big takeaway from the game
more than anything you know hey i'm
excited to see what matt lafleur can
bring to the table and and this new look
packers offense well i don't know what
it is still to this point and i
understand that's the bears defense and
it's going to be one of the best in
football uh the other takeaway i'll i'll
go to and you heard me say in the
opening i think some of these early
games they're going to be they're going
to be ugly you know with quarterbacks
not playing some of the big time
quarterbacks limited snaps limited snaps
are all the starters you know everyone's
kind of getting their feet wet in this
first game they're feeling things out
and we use the the talk a lot you know
the game speeding up or the game slowing
down even for great ones like aaron
rodgers or anybody when you haven't done
anything all preseason you get out there
in real life action all of a sudden in
regular season game number one and the
game can be moving faster guys like that
too and i would expect we see a lot of
that through the nfl uh throughout this
weekend but but none of my questions
were answered about this offense and i
don't feel encouraged about either one
really do you think it's a factor at all
right being in that first game where you
know everyone's watching and it's kind
of easier to be tucked into the relative
anonymity of one o'clock eastern games
on sunday that on top of everything else
you're dealing with yeah this is the
focal point right and it's like a monday
night game sunday night game big tent
game that you know that there's everyone
everyone's watching the whole country
do you think that drags these guys down
a little bit gets into their brains
if it gets into anybody's brains i i
think it would be more the coaches and
quarterbacks where they're going hey if
it's a one o'clock game that's can i
kind of just you know like you said
tucked away nobody's paying attention
quarterbacks maybe feel a little bit
more free oh you know that's a tight
window let me see if i can just throw it
in there but when you get in the big big
game like that and you're under a
microscope
i do think quarterbacks can go oh that's
a tight window i'll just i'll just get
sacked and you know because they don't
want it to become the headline to start
the season right away roger's careless
with the football or trubisky careless
with the football um so you know that
that's that can play into effect a
little bit but it shouldn't it shouldn't
play you should never change the way you
play the game you know depending on the
atmosphere or when the game's played it
was an ugly game each team had 10
penalties in the first quarter the
packers had minus 12 yards of offense
that was the fewest yards in a quarter
and 25 years for the game 467 combined
yards of offense right and at one point
it was that drive in the second half and
it felt like the bears were trying to
open it up they were they were facing a
first and forty after a string of
penalties it it just was an ugly game
and
you don't want the season to start that
way you don't want that many penalties
you don't want the offense to feel so
sluggish and i kind of we we try to
touch on all the possible permutations
of the way things could go and it's easy
to get caught up in that first game of
the season but this isn't the first time
we've seen a clunker like this where
after the fact we're like uh okay let's
get on to sunday yeah right well i mean
i think we even saw it a little bit last
year too you can even you know with
falcons eagles last year it had an
exciting finish because it was very
similar to the division divisional
playoff game the year before so the
scenario was good but the game wasn't
pretty the last year to start i mean i
think nick foles threw for like 130
yards in the game to start that last
last season but you know i think the one
thing okay this is where i want to get
back to there's this is what i should
have said off the top of the show now
that i'm flushing it out in my brain who
the hell is going to help aaron rodgers
out okay because the demons is going to
be good we and we expected them to be
good maybe they're going to be better
than we thought i mean the defense is
legit and mike patton's legit who the
hell is going to help aaron rodgers out
i just don't know who it's going to be
other than devonta adams we're still in
that same little problem there and then
you flip it over to the other side and i
know because i already hear it on the
way to
do the show today trubisky trubisky
listen trubisky did not play well i'm
not making excuses for him but i would
also sit here and tell you i don't know
what the bears offense is i've watched
football for a long time and it's just
all over the place there's no rhythm
tell me where the where the bears
offense starts everybody has a starting
point to say oh this is what we do and
we do it well and then they play off of
that what is it for the bear the bears
it's it's they do everything but i want
to say they do nothing because there's
no timing there's no rhythm to the plays
there's no setup to the plays and i
think that bothers me a lot as well so
before everybody jumps on mitchell
trubisky i also want to say well they're
not very good at running the football
you know the receivers are good okay
they got weapons around him but not guys
that you're gonna go oh gosh we gotta
double team him or we're ruined for this
matchup they got a lot of good around
him as far as the skilled position guys
but i don't feel there's tying the plays
together and just one thing we can say
oh that's what the bears are good at if
teams don't stop that they're in deep
trouble packers defensive back tremont
williams 36 years old the oldest
defensive back in the nfl he said after
the game we wanted to make mitch play
quarterback right we knew they had a lot
of weapons yeah we knew they were
dangerous we knew all those things but
we knew if we could make mitch play
quarterback that we'd have a chance and
that messes with what you were saying
yeah keep him in the pocket force him to
be a traditional pastor don't let him
get outside don't let him run don't give
him those openings yeah where he can
take off
and
it shows that's right he was frustrated
he was never in a rhythm and then
through that interception late in the
game that it ended up being the clincher
and that to me that's the ultimate
contrast
that aaron rodgers touchdown pass yeah
it's kind of this awkward clumsy
guy
and somehow jimmy graham catches it yeah
and the mitch trubisky thing it was the
same idea it was just kind of there was
something about it that fell off right
and that's an interception yes and
that's just like in a nutshell the
difference between the two quarterbacks
it is yeah aaron rodgers made it happen
and aaron rodger was the difference in
the game you know we could say all we
want it wasn't pretty on his on his part
either but you know he just made a few
plays in the game whether it was the
deep bomb a few scrambles the shuffle
passes things like that that changed
field position when they were backed up
at times in their own end zone to where
that really did change or dictate the
flow of the game from that point on
um but yes to back to what you said
you're right that's the thing with
trubisky and that's i think the thing
we're going to continue to see vic
fangio you're talking about them playing
him next you think he's going to be oh
hey bradley chubb bon miller keep them
in the pocket i don't want us going
crazy trying to get sacks i want him to
see i want to see if he can dissect us
like we talked about we talked about in
the pre-game a little bit we talked
about it all week long when you're the
best athlete on the field like
trubisky's been for most of his life
just like a running quarterback he looks
at the first guy and then his comfort
zone is ooh let me run and make a play
and keep him out of his comfort zone
make him be a pocket passer and make him
prove to all of us that he can beat you
that way i think about that who's going
to know how to bottle up true business
exactly deal with and know his
weaknesses
better than the guy who was the
defensive coordinator for the first two
years of his career in chicago i know
it's it's not you know this is a good
way for the season to start for the
bears it is not and to only have three
against the packers and now have that
trip to denver coming up in in nine days
from now it it could really unravel and
they're gonna have to find their footing
and matt nagy the coach of the bear said
after the game uh you know this is
ridiculous three points isn't who we are
well it's who you are right now yeah and
you gotta find a way to to to make it
work and it's just gonna create more
pressure and and already the concerns
were there you talked about it people
were
constantly even last year with trubisky
when things were going well can this guy
get to the next level and defense has
had that full offseason to figure out
what to do with him and here's the
blueprint here's what you do keep him in
the pocket force him to be a quarterback
and see if he can make the throws when
he has that opportunity to to do his
reads and yeah and see if he can find
someone who's open and get the football
to him it's really the big thing it's
like it's he's not going to hear the end
of the scrutiny and the analyzing of his
game until
uh he proves to everybody that he can do
what he did at the end of the
philadelphia eagles divisional playoff
game go down and just okay i put us in a
great spot he's gonna have to do that
consistently throughout the year to kind
of shut up the haters and hey guys back
in the control room i'd love to show the
interception again at the uh at the end
of the fourth quarter it's third and ten
okay so he's trying to make a play and
make something happen like you said with
aaron rodgers okay the difference
between rogers and trubisky's play
rogers played nobody was open and he
said oh i have a six seven guy over
there that i'm gonna give a chance to
now if you're watching on tv look tarik
cohen's open underneath right you see
him there yep that you know so you could
have had herself a situation where hey
don't get greedy here alan robinson's
not jimmy graham from that aspect
there's two guys on him at that point
too you stared him down adrian amos is
over there collinsworth pointed that out
great on the telecast um take the
completion there don't be over overly
aggressive give your give tarikone a
chance to maybe run and get the first
down or nonetheless give yourself a
chance to go forth and short uh but
that's the difference between you know a
great quarterback who recognizes the
situation and another guy who's just
trying to make something happen in the
situation and saying just instead of
just going oh this is what the defense
is giving me and i'm going to take that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports